[Music]
flower power in the midst of communist
era arises in former East Berlin the
flowers don't just attract bumblebees an
ocean of colors is the exhibition's
motto and where the visitors can enjoy
an aerial view of the 100 hectare
grounds where that is exactly what they
see a stop at this viewing platform is
definitely worthwhile this cloud like
construction affords panoramic views as
far as downtown Berlin the rose garden
with its 6,000 different plants is a
particular highlight gardening expert at
an art a bellman is pleased with the
wide variety of the display or zijn and
iron form roses in all shapes and sizes
from ground covering roses to climbers
bed roses everything you could wish for
things you might want to plant in your
own gardens buggy at Russell inflected
in Gotham off lands or on the wall of
your house under house fund and spend a
year come on use in the exhibition zone
flower is a floribunda rose with a
strong scent that can grow up to a meter
high
des comptes and systems originated in my
young friends and it's called mud was in
my young it's our trademark rose another
highlight are the international garden
cap Aneta or garden cabinets landscape
gardens that display a message thailand
portrays its geological formation
history in a water basin catalina lawman
supervise the project the lunches are
taken I'll spunk all the landscape
gardeners from Bangkok paid special
attention to geological processes in
Thailand how the nation came to be
through sea quakes and so on there are
mountains which were introduced in a
very delicate manner his antenna to DC
and they're covered in Thailand's
national colors which is gold deer
Landis far before futile and Steve McCoy
fuzzy in nearby an office from
Johannesburg set up a flowery greeting
from South Africa with a political
message to Berlin this is a team of sky
highed that's famously freedom is the
theme here that's why this garden
resembles the hull of a ship something
most Europeans associate with Africa and
slavery but also shipping goods chef's
home from Bhutan and that's why the
basic structure resembles a ship's hull
the garden is called African bouquet in
Saba African bouquet Danish sculptor
yepper Hine created a maze of mirrors
his modern take on a baroque labyrinth
garden
the international garden show also
provides ideas for creating green oasis
in a concrete jungle with wild prairie
plants or a tropical courtyard a beach
area and mobile flower boxes are the
latest trend much Martin Manifesta stuff
if you don't have a proper garden or
lawn you can quickly create a mini sized
garden with these elements inclined mini
garden suffer the Aquatica promenade
shows water in a variety of ways like
this misty garden with vertical
horticulture this activist besime jewel
amazing is zero it's a bit like a jungle
Sun feel very tranquil
it's interesting how different the areas
are ossified is below the waterfall is
really quite loud so it's like being in
the mountains among the rocks you can
still hear it here but the mist has a
calming effect eternal madam neither the
international garden exhibition will be
presenting international gardening
concepts until mid-october like this new
English cottage with its attractive
flower garden the good news for
Berliners the cottage like the other
world gardens will remain open to the
public even after the show closes
[Music]
as well there's traditional oriental
garden with its flowers and fountains
[Music]
100 hectares in green a place to take
some time out to relax and enjoy nature
in the heart of an urban concrete jungle
[Music]